i've gotten several requests to explain
or teach the mean value theorem so let's
do that in this video so this is the
mean value theorem
and i have mixed feelings about the mean
value theorem is kind of neat um but
when you'll what you'll see is it's kind
of it might not be obvious to prove but
the intuition behind it's pretty obvious
and the reason why i have mixed feelings
about it
is that even though the as as you'll
hopefully see a theorem
as as you'll hopefully see the the
intuition is pretty obvious but they
stick it in the math books and people
are just trying to learn calculus and
get to what matters and then they put
the mean value theorem in there and they
have all of this function notation and
they have all of these words and it just
confuses people so hopefully this video
will clarify that a little bit and and
uh i'm curious to see what what you
think of it so let's see what does the
mean value theorem say let me draw some
axes i'll do a visual explanation first
mean value theorem
i think this calls for magenta so that's
my x-axis
this is my
y-axis
and let's say i have some function f of
x
some function f of x
so let me draw my f of x
oh that's as good as any
and this is some function f of x and i'm
going to put a few conditions on f of x
f of x has to be continuous
continuous
and differentiable
differentiable and i know a lot of you
probably
differentiable get intimidated when you
hear these words it sounds like you know
what a mathematician would say and it
sounds very abstract
all continuous means is that the curve
is connected to itself as you go along
it and and here the conditions are over
a closed interval this is another very
mathy term you'll see
so they'll often say on a closed
interval from a to b
all that means is an interval let's say
a is the low point let's say this is a
we don't know what number that is that
could be -5 or
who knows and let's say this is b
right here let me make b right here
let's say that's b so when people talk
about a closed interval defined on a
closed interval that means that the
function
needs to be defined at every number
between a and b
and the function needs to be defined at
a
and at b if they said over an open
interval between a and b that means that
it's only defined at every value between
a and b but not necessarily at a and b
so it has to be continuous
differentiable and let's say it's
defined
it's defined over the closed interval
and this is just the notation for it
a
b
so that means it has to be defined at
all of the x values
from a to b
including
a
and b if it was an open interval you
would write it like this you would write
a and b
that means an interval for all the
numbers between a and b but not
including those so let's ignore that for
now
so back to the mean value theorem so you
know hopefully what continuous means let
me draw here a function that's not
continuous so a function that's not
continuous would look like this it would
go like this and it would start up here
and go like that right so this would be
an example of a function let's say this
you know same axes let me draw in a
different color
that was our y no that's not a good
if that was our y-axis and that was our
x-axis just to give you a reference what
i drew so if the function
you know is continuous continuous
continuous and then it jumps
that that disconnect that would make
this function discontinuous or it would
not be a continuous function so that so
a function has to be continuous and now
what is differentiable mean
differentiable means that at every point
over the interval that we care about you
have to be able to find the derivative
that means you can take the derivative
of it it's differentiable and what else
does that mean well that means that if
you were to graph the derivative of this
function that it is also continuous and
i'll let you think about that for a
second and actually in this video i'm
going to i'm going to show you an
example of a function
that is
continuous
but not differentiable and because of
that the mean value theorem breaks down
but anyway let's get back to the mean
value theorem most of the functions we
deal with satisfy
all three of these things most of
unless you know you're doing limit
problems and they try to make these
things break down but anyway back to the
function so this function meets all of
these requirements so all it says is if
i were to take the average slope between
point a and point b so what is the slope
the average slope between point a and
point b
well slope is just rise over run right
so what is it
so let me see if i can draw the average
slope
so the run would be
this
distance
that'd be the run
right and this would be the rise
so this is the point
right here that's the point a
f of a
over here this is the point
b
f of b
so what's the average slope between a
and b
what's rise over run
so what's the rise what's what's this
distance how much have we gone up from f
of a to f of b
well the rise over the rise will just be
f of b
this height
minus f of a
f of b
and what's the run what's this distance
what's just b minus a
b minus a
and if i were to draw a line that has
that average slope it would look
something like this we could make it go
through
those two points but it really doesn't
have to
so let me do it in a
let's let me do it in a blue
blue
so that's the average slope between
those two points right
so what does the mean value theorem tell
us it says
if we if f of x is defined over this
closed interval from a to b and f of x
is continuous and it's differentiable
that you can take the derivative at any
point that there must be there must be
some point c
there has to be some point c
where
f prime of c
is equal to this thing
so is equal to f prime of c
i didn't i shouldn't have written it
here
so what is that telling us so all that's
telling us is
if it's we're continuous differentiable
defined over the closed interval
that there's some point c oh and c has
to be between a and b
there's some point between
a and b and it could be at one of the
points but there's some point c where
this the derivative at c
or the slope at c or the instantaneous
slope at c is exactly equal to the
average slope over that interval so what
does that mean
so we could look at it visually is there
any point along this curve
where the slope looks very similar to
this to this average slope we calculated
well sure let's see it looks like maybe
this point
right here just the way i drew it this
is very inexact
but that point looks like the slope
you know i could say that the slope is
something like that right there
so we don't we we don't know what
analytically this function is
but visually you can see that this at
this point c the derivative
so i just picked that point
so this could be our point c
and how do we just say that well because
f prime of c is this slope
and it's equal to the average slope so f
prime of c
is this thing and it's going to be equal
to the average slope over the whole
thing and this curve actually probably
has uh another point where
the slope is equal to the average slope
let's see this one looks like right
right around there
just the way i drew it
looks like the slope there could look
something like could could be parallel
as well these lines should be parallel
the tangent line should be parallel
so hopefully that makes a little sense
to you another way to think about it is
is that
your average let's let's actually let me
draw a graph
just to make sure that
we hit the point home
let's draw my position as a function of
time
so this is something this will this will
make it applicable to the real world so
that's my x-axis or the time axis that's
my position axis
and this is going back to just you know
our original intuition of what even a
derivative is
so this is time
and i call this position
or distance or it doesn't matter
position
and if i was moving at a constant
velocity my position as a function of
time would just be a straight line right
and the velocity is actually your slope
but let's say i had a varying velocity
and and in reality if you're driving a
car you are always at a very variable
velocity so let's say
i started a standstill at time t equals
zero
and then
and then i accelerate
then i decelerate a little bit
decelerate a little bit i keep
decelerating and then i come to a
standstill so my position stays still
then i accelerate again
decelerate accelerate etc
all right so this could be you know i
have a variable uh velocity and this
could be my position as a function of
time so all this says let's say that
after you know this is time zero
position zero let's say after
one hour
let's say that is one hour this time
equals one hour
let's say
i have gone
60 miles
so what can you say you could say that
my average velocity so velocity
average
it equals just change in distance
divided by change in time so it equals
60 miles per hour
miles per hour
so what the mean value theorem says is
okay your average velocity so you could
almost view it as the average slope
between this point and this point was
60.
if your average velocity was 60 miles
per hour there was some there was some
point in time maybe more but there was
at least
one point in time where you were going
exactly 60 miles per hour and that makes
sense right if you average 60 miles per
hour maybe you're going 40 miles per
hour some of the point but at some point
you went 80 and in between you had to be
going 60 miles per hour so let me see if
i could draw that graphically
so this is
this slope is my average velocity and
the way i do it there's probably two
points let's see probably right around
here
i was probably going
60 miles per hour the slope is probably
60 there the instantaneous velocity
probably
there as well
so before i leave let's let's do this
analytically just to just to
i guess work with numbers
and the reason why i have mixed feelings
about the mean value theorem is it's
useful later on if probably if you
become a math major
you'll
maybe use it to prove some theorems or
maybe you'll prove it itself but if
you're just applying calculus for the
most part you're not going to be using
the mean value theorem too much but
anyway if you got to know it you got to
know it and it tells you something else
about the world so it's interesting that
way
so let's say
we have the function f of x
is equal to x squared
minus 4x and the interval that i care
about here is between
is the closed interval so i'm including
2 from 2 to 4.
now the mean value theorem tells us that
if this function is defined on this
interval and it is right we could put
any number the domain of this is
actually all real numbers i could put
any number here so obviously it's going
to be defined over this interval
but so it's defined over the interval
it's this is continuous this is
differentiable you could take the
derivative and the derivative is
continuous
so the mean value theorem should apply
here so let's see what value of c is
equal to the average slope
between two and four so what's what's
the average slope between two and four
well it's going to be f of
four so the change in the function f of
four
minus f of two
divided by the change in x so four minus
two so this is equal to the average
slope so f of four is
sixteen
minus sixteen right
so that's 0. let me make sure that 4
times 4 16 minus 4 times 4 16 right
minus f of 2
f of 2 is 2 squared is 4
right and then minus four times two so
minus
eight
let me try that right four minus eight
right
all of that over two and so this equals
minus four so this equals four over two
so the average slope
from x is equal to 2 to x is equal to 4
is 2.
and now the mean value theorem tells us
that there must be some point that's
between these two maybe including one of
those
where the slope at that point is exactly
equal to 2.
let's figure out what point that is
that's c
let's take the derivative because the
derivative at c is going to be equal to
2 so we just take the derivative so
let's say f prime
of x is equal to
two x
minus four and we wanna figure out at
what x value does this equal to
so we say two x minus four
is equal to two
where does the slope equal to and you
get 2
x
is equal to
x is equal to 3.
so at x is equal to 3 the derivative is
exactly equal to the average slope but
let me see if i can let me get the
graphing calculator here
let me see if what i can do
okay
so here's the graph of
x squared minus 4x let me see if i can
make it a little bit bigger
x squared minus 4x the interval that we
care about is from here
from here to here so the average slope
the average slope over that interval was
2. so if we were to draw the slope it
was like that
the slope would look like that
and
the at the point three the slope is
exactly two so let me actually draw it
this isn't too hard to draw for myself
let me see
so if that's the x-axis
that's
i want that graph out of the way
that's the y-axis
so the graph goes to the point 0 0 i
want to draw this as neatly as possible
nope that's not neat
so the graph it goes something like this
and it dips up and then it goes like
that and i
actually keeps going straight up like
that it's a parabola so this is the
point four
the point two is here
and at two we're at negative four
so the vertex is at the point two minus
four so what we said the average slope
over so this closed interval that we
care about between two and four
it's from two here to four here that's
the interval
two to four
the average slope
is
two it doesn't look like it only because
i've kind of compressed the y-axis
and we're saying at the point x is equal
to three the slope is equal to exactly
that so at x is equal to 3 the slope is
equal to the same thing
that's all the mean value theorem is i
know it sounds complicated people talk
about continue continuity and
differentiability and f prime of c and
all of this but all it says is the
there's some point between these two
points
where the instantaneous slope or the
slope exactly that point is equal to the
slope between these two points
hope i didn't confuse you